foreign
power of Castle hate school I am hella
Mark Harley and today we're just going
to jump right in right off the bat and
do liver King meme of the week why don't
you play that clip there Casey oh let's
take a look at this one oh this is a
good one oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
here's the thing
the name is liver King because liver is
King people are hurting and hating their
lives today so haters will say because
they hate their own lives and this is an
expression a reflection of what they
project to the outside world right
because people hate the lives that
they're living they're suffering with
depression anxiety infertility
autoimmune low energy low libido and low
ambition in life there's a better life
to live this life is full of Adventure
excitement love light and laughter
that's why I'm the CEO of the ancestral
lifestyle to model teach and preach this
way so that we can express our highest
and most dominant form so that we no
longer have to suffer liver King out the
liver King started off as somewhat of a
joke on this podcast uh you know we show
the liver King meme of the week and
stuff like that and as a probably let
you know I've grown an affection for him
over the course of the months let's say
or really the year
um it's probably been about a year since
since he's gained real popularity and I
just
some of my statements you know before I
meet him and and uh
some of my Reflections on the pasture
let's take steroid accusations and even
his controversial diet out of the
equation even though I don't think it's
that controversial in and of itself to
say like eat organ meat and high protein
and earn your carbohydrates is
essentially like that's you know the
level of controversy that he has and
you don't need vegetables I guess would
be the most controversial thing but I
think that's there's evidence of that
you know in
like other when you go to other cultures
that seem to be
um you know not obese right when you go
to different parts of the world and and
uh you know they look at roots or
vegetables for medicine I guess that's
one of his points that uh you know I've
seen him bring up
um I think the guy's a good role model
for masculinity I think that
his ancestral tenants are actually
things that are quite non-controversial
you know when you really look at them I
don't know if you guys have looked at
them but it's things like you know get
cold right I think it's
non-controversial that everybody can
benefit from doing cold bass or ice
baths um
it's non-controversial that uh you know
you should the shield tenant is like
Shield yourself from Wi-Fi and blue
light and all these sorts of things uh
you know poisons Shield yourself from
poisons uh you know either at night or
just in your daily life I don't think
there's much that's controversial so
like as a general framework of
principles for living a healthy and
happy life I actually think his tenants
are quite good and they sort of
celebrate masculinity and drive and
ambition and hard work and a lot of core
values that I think
it may sound obvious to you but I just
don't see celebrated enough in uh modern
culture and uh so it'll be interesting
to talk to him you know one of the
things I was telling Brendan is that
seeing him on the Logan Paul podcast I
was like this guy's fun you know and I
think that's kind of obvious with the
videos but seeing him interact and
seeing that he's okay with swearing and
uh drinking and kind of getting ready I
was like oh this guy looks like he's fun
to hang out with you know and
uh the character that he's come up with
I think he's able to do
because sometimes you go okay you can do
this character in short bursts or
whatever put you on an hour podcast and
it becomes a little bit more difficult I
think he did a good job of whatever and
it's disparaging to say you're staying
in character but I felt like he was
entertaining and compelling for the
length and the entirety of this Logan
Paul podcast and so that further
entrenched you know my fandom for him
and I tried to be honest with myself
about like the feeling that I get when
somebody's coming into this studio
um sometimes I know them sometimes I
don't in this case I'm very well aware
of the liver King obviously but like
it's exciting I'm like I'm looking
forward to it like I woke up this
morning at 2AM and I'll get to that in a
second but like actually more round like
when I was like about to leave you know
I'm like oh my God like I'm gonna you
know he's gonna come on today it felt
like a big exciting day and so I try to
be honest with myself about that stuff
and not downplay or hide that out of
embarrassment or shame that you know I'm
excited that somebody I like is coming
to the studio because there are people
who would would think that who was
stupid that you're excited about meeting
a dude from just because he's famous you
know it's not about his fame or anything
it's like I'm tickled by his content and
his Persona okay we have a lot of things
I want to talk about today this is
probably going to be have to be a
somewhat Short episode because the
limber gang is coming
let's see what we got here so yeah let's
check it let's check out this link real
quick
this dude's hilarious okay this is kind
of like a this is why we can't have nice
gyms thing all right but the white
suddenly stops coming off there are two
possible two possibilities if the
weight's not coming off
steps have gone down you started driving
to coals instead of walking you might
even be fidgeting less during the day
most reliable fix for this track your
total steps make sure that it doesn't
drop option number two and this is
what's happening in 80 of these cases
you're just not sticking to the cows you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] claiming to eat 1800 calories a
day but not losing any weight you are
not eating 1800 calories a day through
the tracking Monday to Friday and then
just relaxing Saturday and Sunday
undoing all your hard work because you
have no idea how easy it is to overeat
when you are hungry or and this one's
common you were tracking but after a
couple of weeks you decide [ __ ] it I
know what I'm doing I'm just gonna do
this [ __ ] by eye now and you stop
tracking trust me when you don't have
the experience portion sizes start
increasing a little bit you start
snacking a little bit more in the day
food just makes it way into your fat
[ __ ] mouth without you realizing all
of a sudden you think you're on 1800
calories a day but you just aren't
partly because you don't have the
experience yet and partly because you're
a [ __ ] imbecile just track your
calories and actually [ __ ] hit them
the weight will stop coming off you know
the hotel reason you should be on or how
to hit those calories then you are up
[ __ ] creek you need some serious [ __ ]
help go to the link in my bar and send
me an inquiry and let me teach you there
we go Okay so
that seems harsh it seems blunt it seems
direct it's but that's all a hundred
percent accurate um and I wanted to put
this up front because I feel like this
is a message that's
worth being repeated if you already know
it I'm sorry but it's something I have
to tell to myself a lot and look I'm in
the process of getting more lean I was
loose with my diet I make all these
jokes about eating with you know
McDonald's but it is true to a degree
we're like I'm just going it's okay to
be a little bit loose with it but then I
go you just find yourself like looking
in the mirror going I'm a little bit
heavier than I want to be I have a
little bit more fat it's nothing drastic
for me that I know I can't undo you know
in a strict month for example of eating
and I like to stay within that Striking
Distance of like I don't want to have to
you know be like oh this is a six month
transformation that I'm gonna undergo
um I but I've developed a pretty good
internal self-monitor of like okay now
I'm too fat I'm gonna start you know I'm
gonna stop eating McDonald's
and it is over for these hoes now it's
it's officially oh can we get some
confetti dropping here it's officially
over these hoes because I have stopped
Beauty McDonald's I've started getting
better sleep I'm doing all these little
things that contribute to better
executive functions during the day
whereby you can
exert more discipline over your own diet
over your own cravings and I think that
the reason this guy speaks to me is
because
I I put all these little blocks in place
it's like get the good sleep
um you know move every day like this
morning even though I was tired and I'll
get to you know how early I woke up uh
for essentially not an important reason
but I was up anyway
this morning I did 10 minutes on the
StairMaster and 10 minutes in the sauna
you might be thinking that's not a big
workout it's not huge or whatever I did
like level six and then level 15 for one
minute which is pretty tough It's almost
like you're jogging on the StairMaster
and then 10 minutes in the sauna and I
stretch in the sun I did some ABS I did
some like other stuff to keep myself
moving but
20 minutes total essentially to achieve
a sweat and an increase in my heart rate
and that can frame my entire day
positively that is enough to get the
benefits of a mood change it is enough
to get the benefits of
a stress reduction it is enough to get
blood flow to the brain even to get
yourself thinking and get rid of that
morning mental fog potentially right so
I'm telling all this because in the
morning I made the decision between
lifting weights and doing that and I
thought okay you know sometimes it you
can have this paralysis by analysis
indecisiveness over what you should do
in the gym I get it and that's like the
benefit of having a structured plan
I don't have that because normally I can
intuitively decide these things
the calculus that went into this morning
was between doing like an upper body
workout really quickly I'm like I know I
can just jump and get my heart rate
going and come back and come here and
the day is Big I'm like I don't want to
be late for all this stuff you know for
my podcast let me go to tfat k then
we're doing Bo nickel on the food truck
so I said let me just get in and out if
you have 10 minutes you can get it going
and frame your whole day positively I
know I'm going to make better food
choices throughout the day because of
that now
I start doing positive things like that
where it's just like little decisions to
like go to the gym instead of not
then at the top of that hierarchy for me
to get ripped
is actually calculating your calories
when I start doing stuff like I've just
described I'm going to make healthy
choices during the day I'm not going to
go to McDonald's today I'm not going to
just eat like a complete [ __ ] right
um yesterday I had some donuts that's me
eating like a complete [ __ ] but not
going to McDonald's but today I won't do
that and I try to take like little steps
towards the finale which is going I'm
actually going to stick to 2500 calories
a day and eat half of those calories
from protein and then 30 of those total
calories are gonna come from carbs and
20 for fat and I'm gonna list it all out
and I'm gonna plan it all out I'm gonna
put it in my fitness palette I'm gonna
hold myself accountable and if I overeat
I'm gonna take it from the next day that
has a 100
success rate
not 90 not 85 100 success rate
if you give me two months of eating 2500
calories a day
and half those calories are from protein
it's impossible for me not to get
significantly more rip so think about
that for yourself
I'm always a little bit surprised and I
don't mean to judge but I guess I just
recalibrate like oh people need to hear
this
they're going I'm eating healthy I'm
working out why am I not ripped
stick to a diet to the tea or you can't
say my diet isn't working right and so
as this guy is saying
it's one of two things and only 20 is
that first option of uh you stopped
moving around as much during the day
which can be an important thing you know
if you're like
walking a lot or even doing like a
construction job where you're actually
physically exerting yourself that can be
significant and so if you stop doing
that but you're eating the same calories
maybe that accounts for not losing
weight but normally it's just you have a
few bites of chocolate and that's like
you know that can be way more than you
imagine for example I came home
yesterday
and there was some seized chocolate that
happened to be laying around did I
purchase it no but was it there yes did
I eat it I'm consciously eating it
knowing and again these are just like
little this is tomorrow today I won't
make that decision to eat chocolate
surround but I go that's gonna oh this
one okay I'm stop eating McDonald's I'm
stop eating chocolate now I'm just not
gonna do that right that's how my mind
works as I progress towards actually
being strict but that you know the three
pieces of chocolate I ate from from
See's Candy maybe that's 500 calories
right that's a lot that could be a meal
and so you have to think about that if I
was calorically neutral now I'm gaining
weight because of that chocolate right
and little decisions like that that bag
of chips that you're mindlessly eating
when you mindlessly eat
you're not tracking it and you're
forgetting that you even ate that stuff
or you're being imprecise with your diet
at least because it's okay to have
snacks like I don't think uh you know
like eating chips isn't inherently bad
but you're probably going to eat more
than you planned or that you realize and
that's why I like single serving chips
for example like the whatever the smart
pop chips or whatever the you know
they're called from Costco it's not just
that they're these like healthy chips
it's that they come in single serving
bags and it's like 100 calories each so
I know you know the moment I eat that
second one well it's not 200 you know
calories whatever
so I just want to remind you guys that
uh
if you actually do your diet strict 100
of the time because even in an hour you
know what I mean like you could probably
eat I could eat 10 000 calories in an
hour maybe that's an exaggeration but I
get a lot like you know give me a sushi
challenge or whatever you can screw up
your whole diet in one hour for the
entire week right you lost like
a pound you know of uh fat during the
week
a pound of fat is 3 500 calories you
think you can't eat an additional 3 500
calories
um in a single setting
it's easy
do it with cheesecake try it out
not that hard all right remember when I
said I was gonna do a short episode and
then I just spent 20 minutes ranting
about the very first topic that's all
right I'll cut it all out thanks yeah
cut it all out
so you might be wondering Mark you woke
up at
2 30 a.m this morning and it's uh
10 a.m right now and you're full of piss
and vinegar and energy how do you do it
what's your secret besides being awesome
well tell you right now it's happy hippo
kratom
did I take a shot before we started
filming a yes
did I dab on these hoes yes is it over
for them since I stopped eating
McDonald's and started taking more
Kratom yes it is go to happyhipple
herbals.com right now use promo code
thick boy three C's take that 20 and
Slice It Off
and enjoy yourself
don't be mad at this Oak and stone shirt
right now I just want to show you what
I'm pairing it with okay
we got some Abercrombie and Fitch
uh cargo whatever pants with the with
the stretchy ankles I don't even know
what to call them joggers joggers okay
it's cargo joggers and I just want to
show you an example of like you know we
got these shoes on this is a designer
fit and it goes well with is designer a
strong word yes but is it you know multi
multiple Brands going on that oakenstone
pairs with I just want to show you guys
this is this is a form-fitting athletic
shirt very sturdy you could wear this to
work out you could wear it out you got
the brand on here it's not conspicuous
it's not
um gaudy or too attention grabbing I
think it's classy I think it looks great
and I wanted to tell you got this end of
the month promo if you come up with a
piece of audio before midnight and
September 30th uh go to my page right
now and you can see more about it
because I use this a dual flip sound and
I do a flip into the pool and then I
come out and then I'm dancing and it's
super fun if you either record your own
audio and I could take it from a video
to
um or you find a sound online everyone
but he's doing these remixes with reels
and sounds and all that if you buy an
oakenstone shirt in the uh before
September 30th at midnight and send me
that Sound I will make a piece of
content I will post it as a real and tag
you as the co-creator of that okay let's
have some fun with it I don't know if
this appeals to anyone but I'm like how
can I have fun and reward people who are
buying Oak and stone at the same time
make sure to use code hella at checkout
for 10 off and again next few days if
you get an idea for a sound that you
find or you make I'll make a skit out of
it and we're gonna remember it forever
what I also wanted to talk about was um
you know I visited my family this
weekend it was awesome I for the first
time I felt like my nephew Amari I go to
see him and it's like oh you're becoming
like a boy you know you're growing up
before my eyes like last time I saw you
six months ago
um your voice wasn't this deep you
didn't have hair you know on your
mustache you're you weren't as tall so
this rat it's almost like unnerving
right and then they're kind of like
their brain's developing too so they're
acting differently and kind of like you
know for the first few minutes he's like
acting like an awkward you know preteen
and I'm like no that's not what the [ __ ]
we're doing you're not gonna act awkward
around me uh look me in my eye and tell
me how much you hate your teachers and
but we reconnected it was fine and my
you know niece is super cute it was just
a great like day trip to go see my
family I left at 3am and came back at 3
A.M the next day
which brings me to my point that I
alluded to earlier which was at three in
the morning uh the producer King of the
sting Nick Davis was he texted me
uh wanting to call me and I just
happened to be up I saw it like I got up
at three to you know essentially to pee
but I'd been getting up early so it's
like it didn't feel like oh my God I'm
super groggy it was like I could kind of
get up right now
and he wanted to talk so I decided to
take the phone call ended up talking for
like two hours
um and he's doing some sort of like he's
making like a video thing where he's
like recording himself for 24 hours like
part of our conversation at least was on
camera
but it was just a cool thing to like
experience where I you know I like Nick
I think it's cool we hadn't really
talked before now we're like
did we just become best friends yes we
did so
uh sorry Casey you know I know last week
I told you best buds for life this week
it's Nick it's just yeah we'll see we'll
see how long you'll come back you'll
come back dude yeah no good luck good
luck with that yeah yeah is he producing
haters we'll say no okay yeah no I
thought so yeah
um
but uh you know
this is another thing that when I get
into this habit I start to like I know
I'm gonna be good for the day if I can
like when I wake when I start waking up
early and I don't go oh [ __ ] like I'm so
exhausted I wish I could just have more
sleep and that happens that's been you
know it's a little bit burned out maybe
the last couple months
and then I just said you know what like
I'm gonna stop
if I have a task to do at night right
your executive functions are just too
drained at night sometimes you go go to
sleep and then just wake up earlier and
it can be painful at first to do that
when you're on a certain kind of cycle
but like actually after I got sick the
other week and kind of just allowed
myself to rest a little bit more you you
get into a point where like okay I can
get back on a normal sleep schedule
whatever and it feels good so I know I'm
very invigorated when I wake up early
it's like
I just I'm more optimistic I don't know
I just like I have this sense like I can
accomplish
more things or I just have a sense of I
can do anything right if you wake up at
four in the morning because you're up
before the people there's just something
that's always invigorating and I get the
night owl thing because there's this
Stillness of night and it's beautiful
and I I you know I'm drawn to being a
night owl to some degree but I just know
that over the course of decades
um the six decades that have been alive
I've realized that I am always just
happier and healthier and make better
decisions when I wake up early in the
morning now
um
the only other thing I was going to say
about that oh I'm taking uh you know
I've been also this has helped me like I
I'm eager to report on this legal and
longevity
allele Rex of Leo and Longevity
recommended to me to take fluvoxamine
it's a SSRI I've never taken ssris
before but he was like any he basically
said any YouTuber content creator should
be taking this
um specific SSRI
for the sake of mental resiliency
and I think I've covered the difference
between ssris and psilocybin I'm doing
both right now on micro dose in the
morning and sometimes in the afternoon
again not to the point where I'm
actually high at all I just notice it
and we'll pitch it to other people as
a sort of mood enhancement I do think it
can work as an antidepressant and the
benefits of psilocybin or that it
creates neurogenesis before
um you know at an earlier stage than an
antidepressant would
so I'm ego I've been taking it for like
a week I think
um
the SSRI fluvoxamine or fluvox and I'm
eager to report if I can notice anything
because
feedback on this stuff seems to be all
over the place and I was always like I
wonder if right like even if it causes
sexual dysfunction or whatever if you're
taking testosterone which I am right now
um
I wonder if like that is weighed out
kind of like finasteride like people
have sexual dysfunction about you know
because you're not getting as much DHT
conversion which is a more androgenic
hormone than testosterone
but if you're taking more testosterone
anyway does that balance out for me it
does I also
I believe I brought this
I hope I did
yes
guess what this is
it looks Russian it is Russian it's
cerebralizing oh genius juice I call it
yeah
um
and I was making a joke I'm gonna uh I'm
gonna go back and find some the
recordings that Leo sent me because I
told him I got they finally got this
stuff
after Leo gave me a dosing protocol and
I was joking with him about like you
know becoming a genius after the first
injection he's like okay so your role I
know you're joking but essentially let
me refine my statements on cerebralizen
to help you guys decide if this could
potentially be something that you want
to get into
he was like it's not going to you know
because he was like well why do you want
to take it I'm like you know potential
CTE from playing football for eight
years potential like recreational drug
use brain damage that I hope to repair
um I'm interested to see if there's like
a subjective difference in experience
like of my own intellect that I can
um you know observe uh you know and he
was like
you're not gonna get smarter
you
can't undo brain damage from
recreational drug use and he kind of
went into like you know if you CR
whatever you take a stimulant or
something and you cause
neurons to die in your brain from being
overly excited which is what happens if
you put a neuron into an excited state
for a prolonged period of time it just
like you know freaks out and dies
essentially it's like overheating you
know the the neuron or whatever the
analogy is like you're overheating this
you know piston and it just breaks down
um
but
what I took away from what he said in
this series of voice notes and I'm going
to ask him for permission to play here
because he has a brilliant way of
expressing all these ideas he
um
was like it creates neuroplasticity so
you may experience brain fog you're
taking a certain dose every day for to
like induce this neuroplasticity and
then you want to actually learn
something so if you have anxiety from
social situations or public speaking you
sign up for Toastmasters
and then you go learn that thing or you
learn a language or you play the guitar
or you but you want to be doing
something that's
you know you're learning and putting
yourself in a different situation you're
stretching your own comfort zone et
cetera so I was thinking about for
myself potentially waiting until I could
link up uh with an online therapist for
cognitive behavioral therapy
I think I'm on the spectrum of add I
don't think that's like a controversial
statement to make but I also like hate
using the term add because it's just
like uh you know dopamine regulatory
system dysfunction probably where I go
some stuff is really boring and
sometimes it's really exciting and it's
maybe a little bit abnormal compared to
the general population for myself
and like the deficits that I have I
think I can work on with you know
because like when I think about therapy
I'm like I don't need to go pour my
heart out about my childhood to somebody
I would like to like learn how to be a
better functioning adult with like time
management and keeping organized and
certain other things that I might have a
deficit for so what I'm saying is that's
going to be my little experiment I'm
going to start injecting this stuff into
my neck uh anything
you crazy I like you dude
and is it does Will Ferrell say that
about him he goes you're crazy about
like you because oh yeah yeah because he
goes yeah you like he's like you go to
Dart in your neck he's like what you're
crazy I like you but you're crazy dude
um best scene ever
so I'm just gonna share like this is an
exciting thing that I just wanted to
share with you guys what do we got next
oh I don't know
um the Hella personality portion of the
podcast I was gonna go a little bit hair
oh there's this other stuff there's a
stuff called
oh God I can't even see that writing can
you pronounce that for me or try it's
like Pi Pi
pyrolutamide pyril lutamide kx826
this is another one of these things I've
told you guys about ru58841 the topical
anti-androgen that you can get at
antigen Inc
um which is in studies effectively as
effective as finasteride uh when it
comes to kind of preventing hair loss
and potentially regrowing some
this is a new compound that's in the
pipeline that kind of like ru58841 it's
like they can sell it to you like for
research purposes well I'm researching
on my own head let's say that
this is another topical anti-androgen
that's making its way I think it was
actually FDA approved you'd think I'd
know this before blasting it out to the
internet uh it with a recommendation to
take it but really I'm just another
thing that I'm interested in
experimenting with as far as using it on
myself you can buy the powder off
antigen ink and then mix it yourself in
some ethanol
and uh it should be good to go so that's
another thing where I'm going to be
splashing that on my head and
experimenting with what's going to help
me not go bald
next up okay you know for a while I felt
like
I didn't want to bring this topic up but
there's been some recent videos on a
Channel about a certain woman named
kalila um you know and it's just
vindicating for me especially with the
stuff that
somebody took a screenshot of like a
comment that I made you know calling her
a narcissistic sociopath which seems
like a really strong statement to make
about somebody
um but you know she did initially you
know she talked about me in public so I
feel like I have every right to you know
address my thoughts and opinions on this
person and as time has marched forward I
didn't want to touch this topic for a
while out of respect for Brendan and the
situation that he was dealing with but I
feel like
time has not been kind to her because as
more information comes out or people
really piece together clips of her
behavior from the course of years and
her statements
we see that my initial assessment is
something that I feel proud to have
stood by
um I came out and said she's a
narcissistic sociopath people were
sending me like
links to people posting on Reddit and
trashing me about it and making it seem
like it's some huge controversial
statement and I was like I'm just
calling it like I see it
um I don't know if I've told you the
story of first meeting a sociopath
uh maybe you'd remember Casey because I
really I Rely in case you remember
everything that I uh talk about on the
show right
um did I ever tell you about the
wrestling coach that I had no Okay so
Coach Joe lesnak when I was 16 years old
um
he essentially weasel his way into this
wrestling program and I say weasel now
but at the time it was like oh this cool
guy who's about you know he's in his 40s
ostensibly he's about as tall as I am
now and um you know very muscular he
shaved his head bald though he convinced
an entire wrestling team and school and
community that he had cancer he did not
in fact have cancer
[Music]
um
he had a very grandiose sort of image
that he in a very calculated way
um
you know sort of infiltrated young
people's minds with like
rumors and innuendo and mysterious
statements about where he came from and
essentially to frame himself as some
sort of like superhero almost
um or a sort of like christ-like figure
who is sacrificing himself you know for
the good of the team this all sounds
crazy but at the time it was like
you know how does this person get into
the situation well one of the top
wrestlers knew this guy from a gym and
like if you can convince one person of
this story and then they turn around
um and you know tell the team you have a
lot of social credit like you know that
works with women too it's like you know
if you're hanging out with one girl and
she's cool with you it's like that that
speaks volumes to all the other you know
if you're with a hot girl and she's like
oh we're friends and this guy's cool
you're pre-vetted you're pre-selected
and so in that same way so surpass
infiltrate
um communities or Social Circles you
know typically via one person at a time
and then that person turns down and
vouches for them and it makes it much
easier to then be gain the acceptance of
those around you
um
Joe again very charismatic when he would
talk to you he made you feel extremely
special
um he would look you in the eye and be
like
your double leg is best double you like
and as a 16 year old you're like oh wow
you know and you kind of pull you aside
like he had these manipulation
techniques that
again I say narcissistic sociopath
because
narcissists often have a harder time
being as calculated in my experience
they can't conceal their grandiosity
um but this kind of you know
covert sociopathic uh you know Behavior
mixed with narcissism
he would always tell these stories at
the right time he would tell kids
stories like he was part of a government
training program in which
um you know they looked for anomalous
athletes and he claimed to have been
both a state champion wrestler in the
state of New Jersey and also an Olympic
alternate for the 1500 meters
like weird things that it's like hard to
verify right to be easier now but like
in the year 2000 you're like oh that
makes sense so they pulled you from here
and then they like put you through like
back-to-back Army Ranger Navy SEAL
training and twice a week they put you
on a uh treadmill with like a VO2 max
monitor over your mouth and run you
until you collapsed think about the
logistics of that like but at the time
it's like okay you're just gonna black
out on this treadmill and then we're
like Gonna Catch You are you in a net
you know what's going on but I remember
that specific story right
um being used as both this like kind of
vaunted like like this guy's a superhero
kind of thing but also
to explain why he had cancer at a young
age because it's like the damage that I
did from this insane government training
program caused the cancer that sounds
ridiculous when I'm saying it now but
like if you imply that
indirectly and with a lot of Charisma to
a bunch of teenagers it's like it's very
plausible in a very closed little space
you know you're in a wrestling room or
you know he took a bunch of kids to like
there's this expensive wrestling camp
that's like all you know a lot of
conditioning except for what it's called
um but you get like a shirt for Grant
you know it's like this one known as
like the I'm gonna feel shitty for
forgetting like oh Jay Robinson that's
what it is he was like I can do Jay
Robinson he took a group of kids to the
woods and like made him carry around
logs and [ __ ] I remember I didn't go
cause I was like yeah that's during my
birthday like I'm not gonna be like
running you know 10 miles in the woods
with a bunch of wrestlers for my
birthday but um you know I heard about
it afterwards and then it's even more
ironic in retrospect because guess what
there was one girl in this group a 17
year old I won't name her name but um
you know you could probably piece
together if you really wanted to he ends
up
having sex with her having a
relationship with her and um you know of
course this is classic anti-social
Behavior because he's he knows this is
wrong it's not a one-time thing he knows
she's 17 no energy and he's manipulating
her and like basically cultivating a
like I'm in love with your relationship
the other coach
um coach Mike Gardner who's only like 25
at the time which is the crazy part he
was like
uh he started a piece together like this
guy doesn't have cancer
you know which is a weird thing to be
like
does anyone else notice that you know
like he still has facial hair and
eyebrows but he's shaving his head and
but he'll like stop practice and oh my
God you know I said you're like oh my
god dude Coach Joe
and remember he put me through this Iron
Man practice one day I was like very
sadistic but he just shows up with a 45
pound plate and like starts making me
like do everything with it and like I'm
running extra Sprints and like literally
trying to like break me mentally or
whatever but obviously I can't be broken
because I'm a Savage and um you didn't
tell me any of it so it's like are you
punishing me like whatever is this
almost like a test of like and I would
be a good example of somebody who would
like had the cardio capacity to actually
do this but then one by one he did this
with everybody would make you carry
rocks or like you had to like pass the
Iron Man you know test uh as part of
like our flip because we also became a
football conditioning coach
Mike eventually like had this
confrontation with him and owned that
wouldn't have been a league like lying
to people about having cancer I don't
believe is illegal just in this context
you know maybe if you're making other
claims to get a GoFundMe then it becomes
illegal with regards to
um you know coaching he like Mike was
like I just want you off this team but
of course like sociopath
you're going to hold on to power
when he uh there's a big fight over it
he gets pissed and goes off and he and
Mike has to come back and tell the team
tells the team they're like all bummed
out about it he didn't say like he
doesn't have cancer he's like he's not
going to be with us this year everybody
runs off except for this girl who starts
crying or she runs like a little bit and
like collapses in the grass and he's
like what happened and she's like we
were in love with each other yeah you
know so that's the end of his stuff but
it always catches up with you right
because
if you're grandiose you're going to make
mistakes like that I'm going to bring it
back to you
this which is if you watch these videos
If you go if you look up the most
sadistic person in comedy
um
you'll see two videos part one and part
two about kalila and I'm just gonna say
I urge you to watch those and I
challenge you I defy you to tell me that
I'm wrong in my assessment that this
person is a narcissistic sociopath who's
obsessed with power who has no empathy
or remorse for her actions who is
interested in uh interpersonal
exploitation and has a long track record
of being a pathological liar when it
comes to her
achievements and her Origins and her
intentions
various scales of Lies you know from
lying about
you know or contradicting yourself why
did you have this tattoo was it cutting
or was it an ex-boyfriend's name
to you know did you get a division one
scholarship to did you go to nursing
school to did you go to Long Beach
Community College or did you go to uh
you know a Cal State Long Beach and get
a Nursing degree who knows but obviously
all these things can't be true at once
let's finish up okay can we do it
this is why we can't have nice gyms
sorry sir your friends can survive this
car accident me in the car window
flexing and I I just rely I was like oh
my God this is the you know this is also
going to reveal me as a narcissist if
not a sociopath but I just related to it
I'm like I could see myself doing that
it's like you know you get the news but
it's just like dude I I look sick in
this car mirror right now like I know my
friends are dead but look at my bicep in
this car window
next up what do we got
why working out of parks sometimes isn't
the smartest idea now it actually is the
hit of the kids had is less severe than
I thought but
I this is one of those things where it's
like hey watch your kid though I don't
feel bad for the kid I don't always mind
seeing kids get hurt like this because I
feel like it's a learning experience for
everybody that guy had every right to be
working out on the thing and uh you know
the kid needs to keep his head in a
swivel and so does the nanny here or the
mother or whatever is going on
um
and this goes with my common theme of
like look everybody's okay at the end of
this you know we're good it's okay to
make fun of kids
this is why we can't have nice oil
changes this is one of the funniest kids
I've ever seen when you successfully
convince a single mom her oil change was
600 bucks to come in hit the chain hit
the headphones it starts just
dropping bars dude
into the Windex
um what do we got next squat spot gone
I'm always amazed at the incompetence
that people have over Square it's like
how you got 500 pounds on your back and
we're like doing this BS where like your
friend doesn't understand now I don't
know whose fault it is initially but
then some guy rushes over here's the big
[ __ ] mistake as he comes over and
like thinks he's helping out by like
lifting one side of the bar
one person needs to spot get behind him
lift him up by the chest I'm amazed at
how like you can be in a gym and there's
heavy weights and like Advanced lifters
and people are still just [ __ ] [ __ ]
up like that all right let's see what we
got next we play the audio on this
[ __ ] [ __ ] them when you're eight years
old and people are still roasting your
calves that is going to be me in federal
prison
um for slander when I keep calling
people narcissistic sociopaths who are
litigious and violent
um
this is why we can't have nice
pregnancies no it is why we can't have
nice pregnancies I just wanted to show
this as an example of like people have
excuses for everything you know myself
included like I'll talk myself out of
going to the gym because of the most
[ __ ] excuses even having a headache
and that's a legit excuse but like over
the decades and I want to encourage you
to do this too look at your excuses
for not going to the gym
and if you're real with yourself and you
really reflect on like you know
is that a real this woman is pregnant
and gigantic and she's squatting like it
almost makes you like uncomfortable
looking at it because you're like that
can't be healthy but it is the baby's
fine and she stays in great shape so
this also this excuse that women have
but also correlate that to yourself if
you're a man it's like oh well I'm
pregnant so I can't work out and I'm
gonna get fat
like oh I'm getting older so I'm gonna
get fat oh I work a job so I'm gonna get
fat oh I can't have access to the food
you know I'm gonna get fat we have a
million excuses like that that correlate
to this but it's like
this woman is nine months pregnant
carrying out a child in her belly doing
power lifting what's your excuse what do
we got next
starting strength coaches uh can we play
the audio on that
it must be low testosterone Mike could
have stopped adding five pounds could
three sets of five be too little volume
no it must be low testosterone my
clients
um so that's just sorry I'm getting a
bunch of text about the liver King as he
wants to meet me
um
kidding but
what I like about this is really funny
because it's like you know oh my basic
ass training isn't working you know I'm
not adding five pounds at the Barbie
time it must be low testosterone now I'm
not saying don't get on trt but this
idea that it's like that's going to
solve everything or that's at the heart
of like you not being able to put on
muscle is complete [ __ ] uh you need
to get real with yourself you need to
see if maybe adding you know volume to
your training spending more time in the
gym right if you can't put the weight up
fix some other vector and increase it
okay because otherwise
you're just making excuses for yourself
just like anybody with the you know I'm
pregnant so I can't work out I have low
testosterone so I can put on muscle stop
being a [ __ ] and do another set all
right